안녕하세요. 시드웨어입니다. 여러분
혹시 리스트라는 사이트 아시나요?
Lyst리스트.이
이 리스트는 글로벌 패션 검색
플랫폼인데 여기서 매분기마다 내놓는
패션 브랜드의 순위를 보면 어떤
브랜드가 현재 좋은 성적을 보여주고
있는지 한 눈에 볼 수가 있습니다.
작년 3분기에 이순위에서 단숨에
12개단을 오르면서 5위를 차지한
브랜드가 있습니다. 그리고 현재도
12권을 지키고 있고요. 제니,
캔달제너, 리안나, 두아리파 등
세계적인 셀럽들의 사랑을 받고 있는
브랜드. 타일리스한 아름다움을 한
몸에 담은 브랜드
알라이입니다.
알라이는 동명의 튜니지 디자이너
아제딘 알라로부터 시작됐습니다.
1935년생인 아제딘 알라이는 튜니지
미술 연구소에서 조소를 전공하고
보그잡지에서 크리스천 디올과 발망의
드레스를 보면서 꾸띠르의 매력을
느꼈어요.
21살의 나이에 아제리는 빠리로
건너가서 크리스천 디올 인턴십을
시작했습니다. 하지만 이민신분이
제대로 정리되지 않아서 다세 만에
그만두게 됐어요. 생계가 불안정해진
아제는 니콜이드 블레지엘의 백작부인의
집에서 베이비 시터겸 옷을 만드는
사람으로 일하게 됐습니다. 리
사교계에 넓은 인맥을 지니고 있던
니콜 백작부인 덕분에 빠리 상위층에서
그가 만든 옷이 입소문나게 되면서
그레터 갈보와 로스차이드 가문 등을
위해서 옷을 만들게 됩니다. 이후
아제는 프랑스 패션 브랜드인
기라로시에서 1, 2년간 경험을 쌓고
티리 미글로와 함께 성장하여 그의
이름을 딴 알라이라는 브랜드를 만들게
됩니다.
이후에 알라이는 여러 굴곡을 겪게
됩니다. 80년대 다른 브랜드에서
선보이던 파워수와 루즈한 실로에서의
복식이 아닌 바디콘 드레스라는
조형적인 디자인의 복식을 내세우면서
알라이는 1984년에 프랑스
문화부로부터 올해 디자이너상을 받을
정도로 패션계에서의 위치를
공고의합니다. 하지만 아제는 본인만의
철학이 확고한 사람이었는데요. 그는
다른 브랜드들처럼 정해진 시기에
SS와 FW 패션쇼를 개최하는 걸하고
본인이 비로서 완성됐다고 생각했을 때
비공개로 쇼를 여는 독립성을
보여줬습니다.
이로 인해서 대중적인 노출이 줄어들고
보그의 안나 윈투어와 긴장감을
형성하면서 브랜드의 명성에 비해서
보도빈도가 감소했습니다. 거기다가
1991년에 아제딘의 쌍둥이 동생이
세상에 떠나면서 미디어 활동이 더욱더
감소하고 컬렉션 발표 또한
중단했습니다.
90년대 후반 천천히 복귀의 신호탄을
올린 알라이는 2000년에 프라다
그룹과 파트너십을 형성하면서제의
전성기를 맞이합니다. 국lin인
미술관에서 앤디 워홀의 작품과 함께
알라이 피스대를 전시하고 2002년
서머 윈터 컬렉션으로 패션쇼에도
복귀했습니다.
이후 아제는 2007년에 창작의
자유와 자유성을 지키고자 프라다로부터
브랜드를 다시 사드립니다. 그리고
여전히 이어지고 있는 리치모트 사와의
소규모 파트너십을 맺게 되요.
8년 만에 공식 런웨이로 빠이
오뚜끝에 복귀하면서 브랜드는 다시
탄탄대로를 달리는 듯했으나 2017년
아제 알라이가 향년 82세의 나이로
세상을 떠나면서 다시 한번 변곡점을
맞이하게 됩니다.
이후 몇 년간 디렉터 자리가 공석인
채로 운영되던 알라이는 2021년
아제 알라 이후 처음으로 새로운
크리에이티브 디렉터를 임명합니다.
바로 현재까지도 브랜드를 이끌고 있는
피터 뮬리인데요.이 피터 밀리는
앤투워프 출신의 디자이너입니다.
피터는 매종 마르엘라에서 4, 5년간
디자이너로 일하고 라프시몬스와 함께
2002년에서 2018년까지 브랜드
라프시몬스, 질샌더, 디올,
케빈클라인 등에서 수석 디자이너와
크리에이티브 디렉터로 활약했습니다.
피터 밀리에가 알라의 명맥을 잘
이어준 덕분에 대중적인 성공뿐만
아니라 슈퍼볼 하프타임 쇼에서
리안나가 또 맥갈라에서 제니 씨가
알라를 착용하면서 패션계에서의 위상
또한 잘 유지하고 있습니다.
피터 밀리에도 2021년 하반기부터
어느덧 약 5년째 알이아를 이끌고
있는데요. 지금 보여 드리는 책은
피터 뮬리에가 알라에서 선보인
컬렉션들을 담은 책입니다. 평소에
집의 인테리어 역할로만 쓰이긴 하지만
이럴 때 아니면 안 펴볼 것 같아서
같이 한번 보고자 합니다. 아제덴
알라이 시대의 대표적인 복식을 꼽자면
바디콘 드레스를 빼놓을 수가
없습니다. 알라이 바디콘 드레스는
우리가 흔히 생각하는 쫄리처럼 비단
몸에 붙는 편안함을 역설하고자 한게
아니라 몸의 실루엣을 조각하듯이
조형해 주는 구조로 제작됩니다. 아지
알라의 전공인 조속과와도 맞닿 있는
특징인 거죠.이 이 바디콘 드레스는
현재 피터뮬리의 알라이에서도 볼 수가
있는데요. 바디콘 드레스는 니트,
저지, 스판덱스 등 신축성이 좋은
소재부터 면과 레더까지 입체 재단을
통해서 다양하게 사용됩니다.
파워 숄더처럼 오버한 실루엣이
지배적이던 80년대에 아제딘이 이러한
바디콘 드레스를 만든 건 드레스를
통해서 여성의 힘과 자신감을 강조해서
여성의 몸을 우아하면서도 강인하게
보여주기 위함이었습니다.
이런 허리를 강조한 실루엣은 알아의
최근 쇼와 캔달제너 등 여러 셀럽들의
알라이 착장에서도 확인할 수가
있습니다.
알라이 대표적인 제품들 중 21세기에
들어 가장 대중적으로 성공을 거둔 건
역시나 가방입니다. 처음 보여 드릴
건 알아의 미나백인데요. 아마
알라이를 아시는 분들 중에는이
가방으로 아시는 분들이 많으실
겁니다. 90년대에 출시된 미나백은
여전히 알라이에서 중요한 위치를
차지하고 있습니다. 제가 보여 드리는
건 미나백 중 25 사이즈인데 이게
생긴 거에 비해서 수납력도 좋은
편입니다. 측면에 거이 잡혀 있어서
짐을 많이 넣을 수도 있고 타팬들과
더불어 크로스로도 멜 수 있어서
실용성도 갖추고 있습니다.이 미나백의
가장 큰 특징이라면 송아지 가죽으로
만든 바디에 레이저 컷으로 이렇게
구멍을 내서 패턴을 담아낸다는
점입니다.이 이 로고 없이도 이런
특징 하나로 알라이하임을 표현할 수
있기에 조용하고 절제된 고급스러움을
온전히 느낄 수가 있습니다.
아제딘 알라이 시대를 풍리했던게
미나백과 같은 펀칭이었다면 피터
밀리의 시대의 알라를 대표하는 가방은
현재로서는 바로 테혈백입니다.
레테켈은 프랑스로 닥스운트를
의미하는데요. 이름처럼 가방이 길쭉한
형태로 되어 있습니다. 튜브형
손잡이로 되어 있어서 탑 핸들로도
사용할 수 있고 길이가 길어서
여자분들이 어깨에 끼고 다니기에도
적당합니다. 미디움 사이즈가 가장
대표적이긴 하지만 이외에도 다양한
디자인과 색상으로 출시되고 있어요.
저는 개인적으로 제가 만약에
여자라면이 가방을 들 것 같습니다.
민화백은 재벌가에서들을 것 같은
고풍스러움이 있다면이 테백은
고급스러우면서도
어깨에 끼거나 탑펜들로 편하게 들고
다니기에 좋은 가방 같아요.이
테백에든 셀럽분들이 꽤나 많은데요.
뭐 제니, 마구로비, 리안나,
캔달제너, 두아리파
이분들의 사진을 보면 좀 이해가 되실
수도 있는데 뭔가 좀 그 고급지면서도
쿨해 보이는 느낌이 되지 않나요?
저는 크게 토트백 사이즈로 나온 테를
주제 넘게 시도해 봤었는데 애석하게도
제게는 그래도 좀 작아서
내려놨습니다. 이외에도 알라이
클릭백도 있고 다양한 형태의 가방들이
있으니 한번 살펴보셔도 좋을 것
같습니다.
알라이라는 브랜드에 제가 직접 입어
볼 수 있는게 많이 없긴 하지만 저는
개인적으로 알라이 데임라인도 참
미적으로 잘 구현됐다고 생각합니다.
특히 몇 시즌 나오는 알라이 라운드
진 실루엣은 캐주얼하게 입기
좋으면서도 그 실루엣이 정말
고급스러워요. 데님 셋업으로 입어도
참 좋지만이 여름에 힌티 하나에
입어주면 그 특유의 여유로움이 표현될
것 같습니다. 사실 제가 지금
입고이는 바지도 알라이데요. 이건
24 FW 시즌에 나온 알라이 울데님
페탈 팬츠입니다. 벌룸피칠의 옆트힘이
있는 패턴으로 24FW 시즌부터 몇
시즌 출시되고 있는 시그니처
팬츠예요. 근데 제가 입은 걸 다
찍고 나서 처음 보게 됐는데 이게
생각보다 트임이 커서 흉하긴 하네요.
여성분들이 입으시면 훨씬 잘 어울리실
겁니다. 근데이 바지에 재미난 점이
하나 있어요. 이바지는 사실 대님이
아닙니다. 울 100%예요.
대님처럼 염색을 하고 대님의 조직감에
더해서 대님처럼 보이게 만든
바지입니다. 실제로 입어본 입장에서이
만지거나 입었을 때 굉장히 부드러운
대임의 촉감과도 같아요. 울대님은
일반 대님 소재에 비해서 활동성도
좋고 국김이 안 가는 것에 더해서
울투의 고급스러운 색감 표현이 된다는
점에서 매력이 있습니다. 흡사이
바나나처럼 생긴 밑단은 무릎 정도까지
트임이 벌어져 있어요. 제가 의도치
않게 보여 드렸듯이 남성분들이
입기에는 조금 과감할 수 있지만
여성분들이 입으신다면 좀 더 매력적인
실루의 표현이 될 것 같습니다.
알라이는이 채널을 만들 때부터 꼭 한
번쯤은 다루고 싶었던 브랜드입니다.
비록 제가 입을 수 있는 남성
브랜드는 아니지만 제가 알게 된 여성
브랜드 중에서 가장 멋있다고 생각이
들었고 그렇게 한 번쯤은 알려 드리고
싶었어요. 물론 알라이를 잘 아는
분들도 계시겠지만 여성 브랜드라
그런지 저도 패션을 하면서 알게 된
브랜드고 생각보다이 브랜드를 가방과
신발만으로 알고 계신 분들이
많더라고요.
알라는 어디서나 쉽게 볼 수 있는
브랜드도 접근성이 좋은 가격대의
브랜드도 아닙니다. 백화점 일부
매장에서만 취급하고 마케팅도 다른
하이엔드 브랜드에 비해서 상대적으로
조용한 편이에요. 하지만 어디서나 볼
수 있는 것이 아니기에 매력적이고 한
번쯤은 경험해 볼 가치가 있는
브랜드라 생각해서 소개해 드렸습니다.
앞으로도 종종 이런 유의 이야기 또한
들려드리도록 할게요. 오늘 제
이야기는 여기까지입니다.
[음악]